You're not the boss of me.
There's an enormous amount of rhetoric out
there about how strong the parties are, how
terrible partisanship is.
In both parties Bernie Sanders and Donald
Trump are supposedly incredibly brave for
taking on the political establishment and
the political parties.
And the simple reality is, if these parties
were so strong and powerful, neither of these
guys would be able to do it.
One of the dirtiest little secrets in Washington
for the last 30, 40 years has been the steady
erosion of the strength of both political
parties.
The era of the smoke filled room where party
elders picked a candidate was done away with
by the primary system.
Reforms in Congress have taken away the political
leverage and power that committee chairmen
and party leadership used to have, and sort
of on every level if you're a celebrity, if
you can get lots of people to vote for you,
that's the only power you need.
One thing that Donald Trump recognized is
that in a democracy, particularly in the modern
media age, being a celebrity is incredible
power.
And if you get people to show up to vote for
you, that's all the power you need to overrule
the political parties.
So what do you think about the weakness or
strength of the political parties?
Let us know in the comments, and also let
us know what other topics you might like to
see us cover in 60 seconds.